everybody must be on vacation.
All right, let's get started.
Welcome to another Zoom call.
And just if everybody reminders go to the members page,
the member site that was built for you,
I change things almost weekly on their look at the new things.
You can order labs on the member site.
We've had a question asked,
can a family member order labs on there?
Um, the answer is technically yes.
Um, it would be best if we did a case review with that family member
and discussed what was going on with that family member.
So that maybe I could give some insight
on what labs might be good thing to add.
But I mean, it was a very appropriate question.
Somebody asked because we did a micotox test,
which tests for mold exposure in your body.
What exposure you've had with mold?
And this, the spouse of this person
since that person's came back positive asked,
can I do that test too?
Well, you don't need to case review for that, obviously,
because mold exposure is going to affect other people as well.
So it's good to do that test.
So, but other tests, it might be appropriate.
And often it is to, for that family member,
to do a case review with me too,
we could discuss that person's case
and how to manage them going forward.
Some people are very astute at their own health care
and they've been to a lot of different functional doctors
and they don't need that.
They just want to run a test.
Maybe that they've already done
with another health care provider at different time
but they don't want to go back there.
So they want to run, let's say,
another Syrex test or just a CVC
or, you know, a bit about a panel or something like that.
So you're funny to do that.
For instance, I put a new blog post,
basic building blocks of a healthy immune system.
I'm actually getting another certification
and I just got one in autoimmune disorders.
I'm getting another one in the functional immunology.
So I'm taking that information
and I'm creating videos and creating information for you guys.
So I just so you know who I am,
I'm just a person who was kind of addicted to constantly studying
and digging and trying to figure new things out to help people.
So I told you this before, but I believe when God sends me somebody,
it comes with a responsibility of trying to figure out
how to help them.
That's part of what I feel like is my responsibility.
So I will be sharing that information up with you.
That's why I've created all the courses
and that's why I will continue to bug you guys
to look at those courses
because I think knowledge is power.
The more you learn about your body and how to take care of it,
the more ammunition you have to fight against
what the world is going to throw you.
So use the courses, go to them and listen to them,
study them, look at any new information we have coming up,
use our blogs as much as possible too.
Okay, some of the questions from last week
that I failed to record the answer.
Are you familiar with the contents of the book, Estrogen Matters?
It was recommended to me, but wondered if you cover
some of that information somewhere else.
And my answer to that is I'm not familiar with that book,
but I am going to get that.
I just got back in town and I'm going to purchase that book
and read it and I will let you know what I think about it.
I have no family history of cancer,
but since I'm under 50 and have my lateral breast cancer,
they suggest I do genetic testing.
Is it information worth having or not?
So the genetic testing that the oncology department
is going to do is going to be for some very specific genes
that can have tendencies to run into family,
that could be a cause of cancer.
Now, they can do some genes that we can't do.
Now, there are genes that they will typically run
when they do that study and what are the bronchagines.
So this person says I was always under the impression
that even if they found the bronchagines
or other mutations,
that should not really change my treatment decisions.
Or would it be helpful to know
if there are any other cancer related genes lurking
in my DNA?
My answer to this is if they're willing to run this test
and your insurance is going to cover it by all means,
I'd say go for it.
Yes, run the gene, run the test.
Now, when we also look in our genetic profile,
we look at your bronchagines, too.
Now, there are, all your genes have family of genes.
So your bronchagines are a family of genes.
There's actually about around 100 different bronchagines.
Now, there's really only, when they do a test for you,
when the oncologist does a test,
they're really looking at about three or four of the bronchagines
because those have been tied to the most significant ones
that can lead to an inability to fight cancer.
So, I just said, your bronchagines are tumor suppressor genes.
There are numerous different families
of tumor suppressor genes like the bronchagines
that if you have mutations, slash defects of those genes,
those genes won't work as well.
Why is that important?
Because tumor suppressor genes turn on
when a cell goes into rapid replication
and it turns on and it stimulates
apoptosis of the cell.
So it can turn on and stimulate cell death
so that that's one way that God put in us
to be able to fight against cancer
because remember, we've said,
what are the struggles with cancer?
Is that cancer is your own cells?
Something gets inside the cell,
damages the DNA, causes the DNA to go into rapid replication.
What could it be?
Could it be a toxin?
Could be a moltoxin?
Could be a pesticide?
Could be an herbicide?
Could be a heavy metal?
Could be a bacteria?
Could be a lime bacteria?
Could be a fungus?
Could be a virus?
Something gets inside the cell
and causes the cell to go into rapid replication
and then it replicates cells
that are also equally dysfunctioning
in a state of rapid replication.
That's what cancer is.
Where that happens,
you have lots of different tumor suppressor genes.
Right now, there's no about 25 different families
of tumor suppressor genes that will turn on
and help cause that cell to go to die.
It's an internal stimulation of in,
what's called an intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
It causes that cell to die.
If you have defects in those genes,
you can have a more difficult time killing cancer
because that you're completely reliant on the external pathway
or the extrinsic apoptotic pathway.
Something killing the cell from the outside,
your immune system killing the cell from the outside.
That's what we're trying to do with the right machine,
stimulate in a viewed response on the cell
to kill the cell from the outside,
stimulate an extrinsic apoptotic pathway.
That's what we're trying to do with nutrition.
That's what you're trying to do with dietary,
that's what you're trying to do with everything else
to try to do with the chemotherapy,
stimulate that extrinsic pathway.
Well, your body has this intrinsic pathway
through the tumor suppressor genes.
What do we have defects on those genes?
We have a more difficult time killing cancer
through that pathway.
It doesn't cause cancer.
If you have a broccogen defect,
does that cause cancer?
That's not what tumor suppressor genes do.
So, but if you do get cancer,
you'll have a more difficult time.
Killing it simply because of that.
But understand, even more widely studied
than the broccogenes are the P53 genes.
There's the K-ROS genes.
There's tons of different gene families
that I look at when I look at your genetics
and that's how I make different recommendations
based upon that.
But long story short,
if they're willing to do that test for you,
by all means, I'm all for testing.
It's just a blood sample.
Let them do it.
I'm confused about the mixed messages
about seed oils on the internet.
They're either from the devil or they're wonderful.
Depending on what site you read.
I noticed my dietary oil recommendations
from color's clinic were devoid of any seed
or not oils other than a wall in oil.
But when I've asked about sunflower oil
and tell me that it was okay to take it,
some people do say that the problem with those seed oils
is how they're processed,
not with the seed oils themselves.
Others say they're generally unhealthy
or our gut's work designed to handle them.
There are a lot of mixed messages about seed oils.
And so let's kind of talk about that.
Just try to be brief.
So the camp that says seed oils are good for you
or is the camp that says that a mother oil
or a parent oil is really what we were meant to eat.
We were meant to eat parent oils,
not EPA, DHA from cold water fish.
So parent oils will break down to that
and will break down to other oils
that's other fats that you need at your body.
And there's a lot of sense that I think about how we were created.
I think there's a lot of sense to that camp.
I don't think we were created and put in a garden
that was close to cold water fish.
So we were created initially to eat plants.
Now I'm not vegan by any search of imagination.
I do think we should be eating meat for sure.
And I think cold water fish is fantastic.
And taking omega three fatty acids is just fine.
But I don't think that everybody,
every human being on the planet needs to go
and start eating cold water fish
and start taking omega three fatty acids.
Good to say, there's people groups that have lived
and they're even in blue zones that live well over a hundred years old
and they've never touched omega three fatty acid
and it's pure fish oil form in their life.
And so there's different cultures that do better
because of genetic variations in that culture
on different food groups.
So I come from more Irish, German background
and I think that there's nothing wrong with me
from that background and culture of not eating a lot of cold water fish
but eating some cold water fish.
I don't personally don't take omega three fatty acids capsules.
Again, I'm not in a fan of you guys
taking a hundred different supplements either.
So do I eat cold water fish?
Yes, do I try to eat all line caught type fish, fresh,
not processed, not, you know, from the ocean fish, absolutely.
Yes, I think it's good for you.
There's a lot of benefits to it.
But I also don't want to say that all seed oils are bad either.
I'm not in that camp either.
So I take a middle of the road pathway.
It partly depends on your heritage.
If you're more Norwegians, Swedish heritage,
you will probably do really well on cold water fish
and they might actually do better for you.
Kidding omega three fatty acids.
If you're more Mediterranean and Asian and culturally
and more African culturally,
you'll probably do better on seed oils.
So you got to look at those things too.
How their process is definitely an issue though too.
If they're cold water, cold pressed process,
seed oils are going to be much better for you.
Plus if they're organic.
So one of the things that we might be having issues
with seed oils is that they're sprayed.
So they might be GMO, they're highly processed
and that's really what's wrong with it.
They might find what's really wrong with seed oils.
Is coconut milk powder a good alternative
if what I was trying to avoid dairy?
Yes, I think that would be a good alternative
in your baking and such coconut milk powder would be good.
On my labs, my fasting glucose is 75.
Why would my human globin A1C be 5.2?
And my insulin B2.8, not lab high but high in the higher scale.
Or is the human globin A1C close to normal?
Seems a bit high but not sure I have followed this test before.
So you can change your blood glucose levels quite quickly
compared to you being able to change your human globin A1C levels.
That's why really a better look at a person's blood picture
for diabetes is human globin A1C.
Because you can get false low glucose levels
because person with diabetes or hypoglycemia issues
or in that range where your prediabetic
can have a spike of glucose after they actually plummet down
so it's actually lower than normal.
They're not taking either blood glucose
at a regular time each time with a 12 hour fast.
They can get some kind of false good glucose levels
where actually their glucose on a 12 hour fast
is raging in the hundreds,
but they're getting false glucose levels.
Now that's what this person is asking
but I just made that point because human globin A1C
won't bounce up and down through the day.
Human globin A1C is a much better lab value
to look at to monitor diabetes than fasting glucose is.
The reason why I want you to look at fasting glucose
is because it's easy to take,
easy to do, easy to monitor at home,
and easy to monitor, easy to prevent those problems
that I just mentioned because you're gonna take it
every morning right when you wake up.
You have a 12 hour fast already
so you're gonna have some consistency
of when you're taking it.
You won't move your human globin A1C
or your insulin as fast.
So as you've changed your diet and you're keeping
your fasting glucose at below 80 on a fairly regular basis
that human globin A1C and the insulin levels will follow.
Understand the insulin levels are also a function
of your pancreas and your cell membranes
as are your human globin A1C.
It takes time to heal those.
So you just have to be patient with your cell.
I sent labs to you.
This is a different lab.
So I know I have to take that into consideration
a different lab company that this person did.
My divided by D25 hydroxy is 127.
So let's talk about that first.
127 on your desolators per milliliter
of your vitamin D levels.
Most physicians will say, oh my gosh,
that's really high stoptake in your vitamin D.
No, I don't think so.
So really, my book, if you're a person with a cancer diagnosis
you really want your vitamin D levels between 80 and 150.
That would be good.
So if it gets beyond 150, then it's time to back off
on what you're taking supplement wise.
But I would say continue unless you're looking
at a trend, let's say three months ago
your vitamin D was 80 and you started to take 10,000 IUs a day.
No, it's 127.
If you continue to take 10,000 IUs a day,
it could be in 177 and three more months.
You might want to back off on it.
So look at the trends.
A calcium is 10.1 up from 9.6.
Why is that significant?
So calcium is another thing that you look at
in your complete metabolic panel or a person with cancer
because calcium levels along with alkaline phosphatase levels
here are an indication of body metastasis.
Well, this person already knows they have body metastasis
and we're monitoring that their calcium level is up,
their alkaline phosphatases up and this is a concern
that I've talked to this person about this already.
But that's what you look at.
So alkaline phosphatase is an enzyme made in the liver.
It will be elevated if there's damage to the liver.
It could be elevated with cirrhosis of the liver.
But another reason why it can be elevated
is if there's metastasis to bone.
So if there's metastasis to bone,
a person's alkaline phosphatase will be up.
So just when you look at one value like alkaline phosphatase
you can't say, oh, this person has body metastasis.
No, you have to look at multiple different things
but this is an indication.
Well, this person knows it has body metastasis
because they had a CT scan showing that.
Other things that will happen when you have body metastasis
you will have elevated calcium levels
because when the cancer metastasis to the bone,
it's lytic meaning that it attacks the bone
and starts shooting away and gobbling it up.
So it'll spill calcium into the blood,
raising your blood calcium.
So it's a lytic lesion.
It's decreasing bone density.
It's a roady bone and it's spilling calcium into the blood.
My tumor markers also went up.
I started on, I just started on a mistletone.
I'll take you to new medication
and the oncologist is switching chemotherapy
and we just started her on Aquabell Pro
which has been shown to be really good
for this type of cancer.
So we hope to see these numbers change.
So this is how you try to manage yourself and manage
your care as you make different changes
and you look at different values
and you're hoping to pray that those things change.
I've been rereading by genetic summary
that I had done a few years ago and I have,
so this person has been a patient for three, four or five years
and we did a genetic workup back then
and at that time we did not give,
so now what do we do a genetic workup?
We give the full report and now the full report
because it's more genes that we look at.
I think when this person did their full report,
the full report was probably like 90 pages.
Now the full report is over 250 pages.
Same font is before.
That's just how many more genes we're looking at now.
And then now we give a full report
plus I give a condensed report or what is called
a genetic summary report.
So on the genetic summary report,
we see I break down that full report
into more bite-sized pieces and highlight the main genes
that we want to look at.
And then I also then give what's called an action step report.
So the full reports about 270 or 250 pages,
the genetic summary reports about 17, 18 pages
and then the genetic action step report
is just about three pages.
So that just gives you, here's your action steps.
And a lot of people will just like,
okay, just show me what to do.
So and that's all you really need to read.
But you also have the ability,
if you really want to dirt out on genetics,
you can look at the full report.
You could go over the you have access to the read your genes course.
You could look at all the videos that I made
on the read your genes course.
You can dig into it even further if you want.
You say it's important to know the big picture
we're talking about.
So I'm currently very interested in knowing if I should add
these two supplements to my regimen pro SOD canalase and cell four
enzyme.
So pro SOD canalase is a PHP product that has SOD,
that stands for super oxide disputease and canalase.
So these are the two enzymes super oxide disputease ever that
ends in an ACE canalase ends in an ACE.
And it ends in an ACE like that is an enzyme.
Those are enzymes that break down proxy nitrate issues.
So proxy nitrate is a very strong oxidant
that can cause cancer.
So you can't go wrong taking SOD and catalyst.
I mean, that's not something.
So whenever I say I don't watch out too many supplements
because your liver has to detoxify them
if you're taking too much stuff.
Well, that's really what I'm talking about is like herbal things.
And we're going to take some other herbal product.
Then if your body can't use that,
you absorb it, then your liver has to get rid of it.
But when you're talking about enzymes,
you can't really take too many enzymes.
You just can't.
Your body will use those.
It'll break it down into proteins.
You'll use it to make other enzymes
if it doesn't eat that enzymes.
So you can't really overdose enzymes.
It's not really possible.
And then so yes, you could take that.
Now, you are, believe I, you were taking other things
that had SOD canalase in it.
So I was just trying to keep you to lesser amount of supplements.
So for azim is a product from US enzymes.
It's got so forafade.
So forafade is the main product in broccoli extracts
that can help with estrogen dominance.
It helps with estrogen's out and can be great
for estrogen dominant cancers.
Now, I believe you're taking other things to do the same thing.
And you're taking other things that probably have that in it.
And then because it's a US enzyme product,
all US enzyme products also have at least
astrocym, which is there at an enzyme, if not
on their enzymes as well.
So you could take these.
There's no negative about that.
So I believe the SOD effects copper.
Well, really SOD really pulls out a proxy nitrate.
So proxy nitrate is really broken down through the SOD and canalase.
So I'm going to check out the site to see if you could
get products from for your vacation.
Yes, I'll do that.
My colleges is telling me that no one with cancer
should be on an acetylcystide.
What are your thoughts as to keep taking it or not?
Also, you put me on a cobalt pro twice a day after taking
the even dose of my kidney cert.
I'm trying to drink a large glass of water with the tablet,
but I'm not dehydrated.
So that can be an effect of this because it's a very strong
different type of herb that can be really good for your cancer.
So make sure you're drinking.
I would just keep doing that.
That is the recommended dose.
So I would not lower the dose on that.
As far as this question, why the colleges say no one should be
on an acetylcystide, the only thing I could think of,
I'm trying to get into his head and think of why he would say that.
So an acetylcystide, it's a very strong antioxidant.
Now, an oncologist is usually giving what?
Keynote therapy.
What is keynote therapy?
An oxidizing agent.
What is an oxidizing agent?
Poison.
What does that mean?
That's just what an oxidizing agent is.
It's a poison.
The truth is, we need oxidizing agents in our body.
But the problem is we get way too many oxidizing agents.
What do oxidizing agents in our body do?
Remember, I've said over and over again that don't list things
as good versus bad.
I mean, things are good versus bad if they're
own of balance, right?
So God created us that we need oxidizing agents.
What do oxidizing agents do?
Oxidation in our body kills pathogens.
Period.
That's what it does.
Oxidation kills pathogens.
Helps our immune system kill pathogens.
Oxidation also can help kill cells that are damaged too.
So the idea of why do we give an oxidizing agent?
AKA a poison to a person with chemotherapy or person
with cancer called chemotherapy is really
because the idea is that cancer cells are going
to be less stable than healthy cells.
And they won't be as able to withstand a chemical poisoning.
So if we poison this person, the cancer cells will die first.
That's quite honestly that is the truth.
That is the simple explanation of chemotherapy.
And I don't say that to knock it because it can be a huge blessing
because lots of times it works exactly that way.
So but enacetyl cysteine isn't antioxidant.
Enacetyl cysteine isn't antioxidant.
It works as an antioxidant itself.
It helps form glutathione.
It gives off the cysteine for glutathione reformation
after glutathione is oxidized
and the process of acted as an antioxidant.
So glutathione is recharged and recycled inside the cell
and it needs cysteine to do that.
Enacetyl cysteine really helps with that.
So my thought is that an oncologist
is saying no cancer patient really should be on any antioxidant.
And what he's saying is that because I'm giving them
chemotherapy, I don't want them taking antioxidants.
So that's why he's saying it.
At least that's why I think he's saying it
because there's any further sense in saying that.
So again, what we tell people is if you're going to do chemotherapy,
if you're doing chemotherapy inclusions,
don't take antioxidants for 24 hours
because that's really what the chemotherapy
is really actively killing cancer cells.
If it's not killing, beyond that,
it's just damaging healthy cells.
And you should be taking antioxidants
to protect your healthy cells.
Matter of fact, the number one reason why a person
not cancer in the first place is because of a deficiency
in antioxidants.
Why do you say that?
Because what's the number one cause of cancer?
Remember I said heavy metals, toxins, pesticides,
mycotoxins, getting inside the cells
and damaging the DNA of the cell.
What are those things that I just mentioned?
They're oxidizing agents.
That's what they're doing.
And they're actually oxidizing.
That's the process of the damage.
When I say damaging the DNA, it's an oxidative process.
So if we all had more than adequate antioxidants
every second of every day, the chance
of us getting cancer quite honestly would diminish greatly.
So to say that no cancer patients should be
on antioxidants is like you're just cursing that person
to not be able to fight off further cancers,
not be able to fight off stance cancer stem cell
circulated tumor cells that want to raise a whole
with another place in your body, not being able to really
win the battle that they're trying to win.
So it's just ridiculous.
So I would agree with the oncologist
that a person with cancer should not take antioxidants
for 48 hours after their IV infusion,
but after that you should load up on antioxidants.
Glutathione, alpha-lopiac acid,
curcumin, vitamin C, all these great antioxidants
that we are so, I wouldn't say we're deficient
in antioxidants as a nation, as a human race,
I would say that we are over abundant in oxidizing agents.
So remember I said it's balance, right?
We need some balance of oxidation taking place in our body,
but the problem is we are so out of balance
because we are exposure to chemicals and heavy metals
and poisons in our environment to toxins
and these chemical companies didn't exist
150 years ago.
Now we're kicking out all this stuff and causing
just damage to ourselves and we don't even know it.
So really important that we are taking
into oxidant nutrition to help our body fight this.
Okay, some questions that came in.
I traveled with my right machine for the first time
ever in breeze through TSA.
No interest in even looking at it.
One more praise report Dr. Cutters,
the clear talks is really working
I'd like tonight is, oh fantastic.
So this is the first time, so this is a brand new product
for us, clear talks.
It was designed to help detoxify mRNA vaccines.
That's what it was designed to help detoxify,
but it's really good for your blood vessels.
We also have another product that's very similar,
it has a lot of the same ingredients
called clear circulation.
That's really good for your blood vessels too.
So I don't know if it's working on the pathway
of actually pulling toxins out that's affecting
your tympanic membrane or affecting the tympanic nerve
or pulling toxins out across the blood brain barrier
that's affecting the temporal lobe of the brain.
Is that all ties to Taditis?
Or it's just, remember I said that the inner ear
is what are called terminal vessels.
Vessels that don't anastomatize,
so you have anastomocene vessels most every place in your body
where you have two vessels that will feed the area,
not just one, but in the heart and in the inner ear
you have what are called terminal vessels.
So if you damage a vessel or one vessel is blocked,
you're gonna have like a midi stroke to the inner ear.
And that's what a lot of the theories on Taditis are.
So working on those vessels and some of the things
that are in clear talks actually do that.
The nanocardase and the lumbarocardase,
especially can help open that up.
So praise God, we'll have to share that with other people
with them Taditis.
Why can lipidema have delayed onset?
So the question really need to ask is
what is causing the lipidema?
So lipidema just means there's a block
it just in the lip vessel and there's adema,
delves, stream or backstream from where the blockages.
That's what lipidema is.
So we gotta look at cause.
So if the delayed onset you're speaking of
as I had lip nodes removed and then I had no problems.
And now I have lipidema in my arm.
And I have let's say lip nodes in my left axillary area
removed, I had no issues and now a year later
I have swelling in my left arm.
How could that's delayed?
Well, it's because if you had some of the lip nodes,
some of the vessels removed what drains that arm
and you don't have any extra swelling there to that arm,
you might not notice anything,
but then you get a bum bite or something like that in that arm
that's gonna cause it inflammatory response.
Now there's not enough lip drainage in that arm
that you're exceeding the inflammation in your exceeding
the ability for that to drain.
So you're gonna have to work on it,
you're gonna have to do some massage,
you're gonna have to do some cold packs,
you're gonna have to look and see what could be a cause
of the increased inflammation,
what's, or the edema,
another word for it and see,
okay, if you kinda go,
well, I know what the lip blockages from,
it's from the removal of the lip nodes.
Okay, well, we got that figured out now
what's the cause of the increased inflammation?
Can't just be the heat,
you know, you'll be outside working in the garden
and that's gonna be a source of inflammation right there.
So find the source of inflammation
and then work on some of the other techniques
of getting some lip flow going.
I asked this email question,
but driving and losing signal,
I will listen to the recording,
but another point I'd like to hear your thoughts on,
I just found a Mercola article on seed oils
and that oils and his problem with them
is the high little egg acid content.
Apparently, this is the new bad boy
causing nearly every chronic illness.
Have you heard of this?
Yes, and I'd be careful of that.
I'd be careful of the new bad boy causing every illness
and I like the way you phrase that
because I love Dr. Mercola.
Actually, he was gonna have him on my podcast,
and write before a COVID hit.
And then we had to end it up canceling it.
And as much as I love him,
he's like a sales genius in a way.
But I hate, I have a real problem
with all these nutritional people on Instagram
and Mercola, you know, sends out a newsletter every day
and I just pray that I don't do that.
And like, whoosh things on people like,
oh, here's the problem.
Oh, here's the thing.
You get to the point where these people
are even contradicting themselves
and just to get likes, just to get followers,
just to make money, it just bounces down to claim it.
And if they have this, you know, X amount of followers
and they can sell ads and blah, blah, blah, blah.
You just gotta be careful of all that nonsense.
And I always just bring things back to,
okay, how did God create us, okay?
He created us to eat whole foods.
Let's do that as much as possible.
And, you know, there isn't necessarily bad boys
and good boys, it's too much of things.
Again, just imbalance.
It's like, okay, even, okay, don't eat any sugar
because you're trying to keep your glucose levels down.
What's this mean?
You can't have sugar once in a while.
You know, it's not like an evil curse.
You know, so God created all things for us to enjoy
with imbalance.
So just keep that in mind with that.
Do you know, Dr. Jack Cruz?
And if so, I would love your thoughts
on his teaching about the sun and mitochondria.
I don't know, I do know of him
and somebody asked a question about him.
I think last summer, they were,
and I looked up more things on him.
I've never interviewed him on my podcast.
I don't believe, but I don't know what he teaches
about the sun and mitochondria.
I do know that there was some information going around again.
This is, we have to be so careful.
There's so much not corrected information going
around social media is one guy who is a carpenter
in my house, he's become a real good friend of mine.
He's built some bars for me and stuff.
He said, oh, you should never wear sunglasses
because you need the sun to hit your eyes.
So that's blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And it's like, you know, he doesn't listen
if I try to tell him anything.
I just nodded and said, thank you.
But then it's so not true.
You realize stimulation on your eyes with the sun.
Is that bad for you?
No, it's not bad for you.
But it does stimulate your sympathetic.
That's the whole purpose of it.
It's just stimulates your sympathetic.
Do I need more sympathetic stimulation?
I don't know about you,
but I need more parasympathetic stimulation.
Talk about it balance.
I am way overly sympathetic stimulator.
Okay, you know, I deal with enough stress in my life.
I don't need the sunlight, you know,
say in somebody that, you know,
doesn't know what they're talking about with the nervous system
that everybody should not wear sunglasses.
If you are overly sympathetic dominant,
you should be wearing sunglasses
because that will block out some of the light
and calm down your sympathetic.
So just this information like that is just damaging to people.
So it, and it just seems like so many people
say these things that are kind of outlandish
so that they can get more likes and more followers
and that bothers me.
What is your opinion on using diamonds peptide
for the immune system and using carbon 60
as an antioxidant for free radicals?
I think thymus extract is very good and it's great.
But again, yes, your T cells are made in your thymus
and giving, if that's the reason why you have low lymphocytes
is because of damage to the thymus,
especially if you have radiation to the thyroid gland
or radiation in that area,
then I think it's an order.
I don't think everybody needs to take it
but I think there's nothing wrong with taking it.
Using carbon 60, there's some articles on carbon 60
that came out and it's this wonder antioxidant
that keeps you, it's the function of use.
That's what they called it and stuff.
Again, way over selling stuff.
So there's a lot of good antioxidants out there.
This is what it's just, when I looked at it at that time,
it was like very expensive.
It's like, I'm not even going to sell that in my store
so I'd ever carry it.
It's just, to me, it was just way overpriced.
Why is it not good to do vitamin C infusions
while taking fendabasol?
Going on and saying, I've never heard that.
So I don't know who's telling you that.
I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it.
It's totally different pathways.
Fendabasol's not working on an oxidative pathway.
So I don't think there's anything wrong
with taking those two together, but I could be wrong.
I had a bad case of COVID way back then,
but way back when, but was never got the vaccines.
Okay, so you're the one that's taken the clear talks.
Yeah, that's good.
You're still exposed to the NREA by people
that you know that were vaccinated, though,
and you're exposed to it just by COVID.
So it's still good to pull that out.
If I were to take U.S. enzymes, so far as I,
in which you stated earlier on this call today for estrogen,
COLMT on my genetic test, COT defects on my genetic test
in dopamine, could I delete the aroma clear,
which has dim and for COLMT dopamine?
So for a fade, that was on genetic.
I think the, honestly, I think the aroma clear,
the aroma clear is a better product.
So it's got several things in it
where the, so far as I've just got one dig in it
and the enzyme, so.
Yeah, those are totally different supplements.
I would say the aroma clear
would be a better product for you.
I haven't taken a homeopathic product called T Relief Artica
for arthritis pain in my wrists,
caused from the immunotherapy.
So understand my belief with homeopathy is that,
homeopathy can be fantastic.
So we personally, as a family, use homeopathy for pain,
homeopathy, and you can also get homeopathy as an herb
for pain as well.
We use that for pain.
My kids give that to their, my grandkids,
that's a main thing that they have in there.
Arsenal, we went on a family vacation
number of weeks ago and my daughter,
law had homeopathy for homeopathy for homeopathy
and her son heard his ankle
and first thing they gave him was article for pain.
It works well to relieve the pain.
However, I just noticed one of the active ingredients
is lactose.
You don't have to worry about that.
So I stopped taking it as I know that there,
don't worry about that.
So you're not, you're not,
not taking dairy because of the lactose.
So lactose is the sugar in dairy.
There is not enough lactose.
You in the homeopathy of article to even register
in your, in your body.
You're not, not taking dairy because of lactose.
It's not the lactose in dairy
that is the suggestion for you to not take dairy.
So go back and use the article that's just fine
if it has lactose.
So it's the lactose that ingredients the tablets
save the, as dairy, no, it's not.
So understand dairy has lactose in it,
but that's not why I'm not having you do dairy
is because of the lactose.
Other things have lactose.
Lactose is just a sugar.
So go back to take that.
Bioclin phosphatase has been creeping up
was considered low at 28 to 30.
And since I have started the hormone blockers,
it's been up to 35 to 40, 45 in the last three draws.
I would suggest that it's because of the horrible,
it's because of the drug itself.
So the hormone blockers, remember, that's a drug.
And your liver acid detoxify it.
And it's just, rest of your liver just a little bit.
I wouldn't be concerned about levels like that though.
I, I'd say it's the drugs.
Calcium is balanced around.
So just keep an eye on it.
You're looking for patterns.
It's not as extract different than the thymus peptide.
Yes, so peptide is different than a thymus extract.
I am not a big fan of doing any peptides
with cancer patients,
because there can be stimulus of growth with peptides.
I would say, stay away from that and go to a thymus extract.
I know biotics research has a good thymus extract.
That's a brand that I would trust for thymus extracts.
You have to call the office to get that,
because we can't have it on the website.
You had told me to tell me not to do the vitamin C infusions
while getting rid of parasites with venbenazole.
But she told me to ask on the show why this is
because she didn't know why.
I think the other reason I told you, I don't know why.
I don't think what I was, if I said not to do the vitamin C
infusions, it's not because you're doing parasites with venbenazole.
Vitamin C infusions, maybe I thought when you were talking,
which you asked her the question,
that you were asking a vitamin C infusions were beneficial
to clear parasites with the venbenazole.
And my answer, if that was how I thought of it,
my answer would have been no.
You don't need to do vitamin C infusions
are not going to be something that would be
another list of things that I would do to clear parasites.
So my thought was that I don't,
I think she just asked me would vitamin C infusions be good
to help with venbenazole,
to clear parasites, my answer would be no.
If you're taking vitamin C infusions for cancer,
and then you're taking venbenazole,
there's no contraindication there.
But I wouldn't do vitamin C infusions for parasites,
nor would I do vitamin C infusions
to help with venbenazole's ability to help with parasites.
I think that completely independent,
and I don't think that's gonna do it for that.
So I must understand the question.
That's why it's always been a schedule of time with me.
So is hista DAO just as good as histamine scavenger?
They're completely different.
So we have a product that's called hista clear.
It is DAO enzyme,
which is the enzyme,
which clears histamine.
But it clears histamine wherever it's located,
you don't absorb it.
It's too large of an enzyme for you to be absorbed.
So it really is primarily working in the gut itself.
So you would take hista clear or hista DAO enzyme
other companies make it as well,
to help decrease histamine in the gut.
You don't take it to help remove histamine in the tissues.
So you need other herbal products
to remove histamine from the tissues.
And our histamine scavenger or clear histamine scavengers
is a good one to do that.
We also have natural clear hista,
which is a different mix of combination of things
to do that as well.
You can look at the back of the histamine scavenger
bottle on the website and see the different,
the reason why I like that is it's got a lot of different
nutrients in it that will deal with different pathways.
A lot of products just have corseted
and a few other things that will pull out histamine scavengers,
number of different things.
So the histamine,
hista clear or the DAO enzyme
is completely different
than a histamine scavenger or natural clear hista,
and that the hista DAO enzymes work.
Primarily in the gut do not get absorbed,
do not pull out histamine from the tissues,
histamine scavenger and natural clear hista are absorbed,
they pull out histamine from the tissues.
But you said it was okay to take vitamin C supplement.
Yes.
Can I take paraclerosis from endosol?
Yes, you can.
Doing the same work,
if you're taking fend bentosol for parasites,
can you take paracler?
Yes, it's working on,
if endosol is a medication to kill parasites,
paracler is an herbal combination to kill parasites,
you're doing the same thing.
Do you need to do both?
No, you could try one or the other.
If you're taking fend bentosol for cancer,
totally different thing.
So when you're taking fend bentosol for cancer,
you're not trying to kill parasites.
You might kill parasites while doing it
because it is going to work on parasites if you have parasites.
So just so just so you understand,
I'm taking four parasites.
Okay, well, you can take paracler with it.
Certainly can, there's nothing wrong with,
you won't hurt yourself by doing that.
And you won't hurt yourself by taking vitamin C with it either.
I still, vitamin C really isn't the greatest parasite killer,
but it's certainly IV vitamin C.
Taking oral vitamin C can work with your gut a little bit more.
IV vitamin C, I wouldn't use that for parasites.
So, did you ever blog about Taditis?
You said you were going to.
I know, not the last week here I did it.
The cancer reacted very well to vitamin C.
Okay, that's good.
Well, you could keep taking vitamin C with the RGC testing.
Okay, there's nothing wrong with, do we,
you know, there's nothing wrong with doing it?
I just misunderstood the question,
is that you had to do that with that?
That answer, no, they're totally different pathways.
Okay, well, this one did get recorded,
so I'll get it up.
I'll energize for that.
Thank you all for participating.
This was your first time, hopefully you learned something
and you can listen to it afterwards.
If you want to, we'll have an app of the CB for sure.
God bless all of you, no, I love you,
and I prayed for all of you, and we'll see you next week.
Bye-bye.